cada año en julio empieza la temporada
de los incendios en el pantanal sin
embargo han sido mucho más intensos este
año la superficie quemada desde enero
hasta hoy es de 19.000 kilómetros
cuadrados lo que representa 10 por
ciento del bosque pantanero el mayor
humedal del mundo compartido con bolivia
y paraguay tiene una de las
biodiversidad es más ricas del planeta
la semana pasada cerca de aquí casi se
destruyó un bosque que era un refugio y
lugar de reproducción para waka muelles
azules especies amenazadas aquí en el
pantanal han sido montadas tres bases de
lucha contra el fuego por las fuerzas
armadas que han llegado aquí a finales
de julio para proporcionar un apoyo
logístico con aeronaves para que los
bomberos puedan llegar a los lugares de
más difícil acceso a la región vive una
sequía histórica según los especialistas
es causada por un desequilibrio
climático el pantanal depende del agua
que viene de los bosques del norte del
estado de matto grosso
en la región amazónica donde llueve cada
vez menos a causa del desmatamiento y
del avance de las tierras agrícolas
aquí en la mayor reserva privada del
país los bomberos luchan desde el inicio
del mes y hace que 50% del bosque de la
reserva